الحديث هو عن ازمه طاقه في اوروبا في
الشتاء المقبل يتجدد في وقت مبكر
والاستعدادات لتجنبها تبدا الان يقول مشغل
تخزين الغاز الرئيسي في المانيا اي ان اي
اس ان برلين من المرجح ان تصل لمستويات
تخزين الغاز المستهدفه في وقت مبكر هذا
العام لكن خطرا النقص لا يزال قائما السبب
في ذلك ان المانيا تراهن على شتاء معتدل
لا تذهب فيه درجات الحراره بعيدا عن خط
الصفر تماما كما حدث في الشتاء الماضي
المعهد الوطني للاحصاء الالمانيه يقولوا
انما انقذ البلاد الشتاء الماضي ايضا هو
تخفيض الاسر للاستهلاك واغلاق قطاعات
صناعيه ضخمه كالزجاج مثلا والان يعود
الحديث عن التقشف الصناعي في المانيا يقول
وزير الاقتصاد روبرت هابيك ان المانيا قد
تضطر الى خفض كبير في الطاقه الانتاجيه
اذا لم تمدد روسيا واوكرانيا الات فاقيه
المتعلقه بنقل الغاز الى اوروبا ويضيف اذا
لم يتدفق الغاز الروسي الى اوروبا الشرقيه
بالاحجام التي لا يزال يتدفق فيها عبر
اوكرانيا فسنضطر لتقليص انتاجنا والا
سيتجمد الناس
[موسيقى]
ولكن لدى اوروبا خطه خطره بشان تامين
احتياطاتها من الغاز التخزين في اوكرانيا
التي تخوض حربا حول وجودها على بعد نحو
100 كم من حدود اوكرانيا مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي وتحديدا بولندا توجد منشاه بلشي
لتخزين الغاز
اذا تلتقي الانابيب التي تحمل الغاز من
روسيا وبيلاروسيا في هذه المنطقه القريبه
من الفيب عاصمه الغرب الاوكراني ومن هذه
المحطه تنطلق الانابيب لتمد دول اوروبا
الشرقيه بالغاز المحرك الرئيسي لاقتصادات
تلك الدول
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات